you have clearly had a busy busy week a
lot of news we've got to ask did you
look at your company today and that
outlook all that cash you've got not
much leverage what are you going to
spend it on how about valiant for
example yes so nice that to be with you
this morning look we're in a terrific
position while this was not plan a we
were prepared for this we had a
contingency plan and Allergan has a
great opportunity as an independent
company to leverage its growth profile
its large R&D assets and of course as
you just mentioned our balance sheet and
so we will continue to look to become
the premier growth pharma company and
we're going to go and look to find
assets that complement and increase our
growth profile is that would valiant be
one of those complements yeah I can't
comment on a specific company but keep
in mind the attributes of things we buy
are always growth oriented or R&D assets
in our seventh when in one one of our
seven therapeutic areas you know valiant
I'd really have to understand their
growth profile to be to be able to
answer that question and you don't
understand their growth profile or you
don't like it well they haven't reported
right they it's hard to see what was
volume versus price it's a got a lot of
good assets in there they have a lot of
good people I used to be the CEO on
Bausch and Lomb that's a premier brand
and I care but I can't comment
specifically on value because I just
haven't followed it that closely would
you be interested if they were willing
to spin out bow alone well as I said
Bausch and Lomb is a premier asset and I
care I haven't followed it closer they
operate in this different segments of I
care than we do we're a pharmaceutical I
care company they have more of a bent
towards consumer like contact lenses in
surgical but I know the business well I
like the people there and I'd have to
really understand the pipeline and the
growth prospects of that business given
these new treasury rules and I know you
don't want to comment on specific
acquisition targets with something like
an AM Gen be too big no actually you
know again I can't comment on engines
specifically but really these new rules
have no virtually no impact or no
Tero impact on stand-alone allergen both
the income stripping as well as the
three-year look-back provisions really
don't impact a company like our again
particularly as we get to October this
year and the third year anniversary of
our Warner Chilcott deal now what you
think about what kind of deals you want
to do next and you'll have a lot of cash
once you're done with the tether
transaction are you thinking more in
terms of R&D heavy organizations or are
you thinking more in terms of the
branded pharmaceutical space really
we're going to look at both and
everything we're also going to look at
other ways to improve our return capital
to shareholders and so everything is on
the table the end of the day the most
important thing that we can do is stay
focused on our strategy of executing our
business driving double-digit branded
growth and looking for opportunities to
enhance our growth profile whether it be
through our D assets or marketed
pharmaceutical products how about your
profile Brent you are known as the deal
guy and clearly this breakup happened
very quickly could that mean if Pfizer
let's say broke up into two companies
could you be the buyer of one of them
you like Pfizer I do like Pfizer and I
have tremendous respect for you and Reid
and the management team at Pfizer and
they are also prepared for this
contingency and they're gonna do great
look we're gonna look at anything that
is a growth oriented asset that's what
we do we're a growth pharma company and
that will include R&D assets as well as
marketed product as I said before so
everything is on the table everything is
a possibility but it always will be true
to our growth profile and growth
oriented assets now you spent a lot of
time with Pfizer over the last few
months you were on an executive
committee that would have potentially
helped run the company what do you think
Pfizer should do next well look i Pfizer
has a strong plan as an independent
company Ian Reed is a terrific CEO and
so they're going to move forward on
building their business doing great
things in oncology vaccines rare
diseases inflammation so they're they're
in a very strong position and they're
gonna do great all right let's talk
about your position you have said
the past that you are on the path to $25
earnings has that changed or does it
need to now no look we're we're focused
on shareholder return and looking for
opportunities to create cures and
treatments for unmet medical need that's
our mission right and so the fastest we
can get to 25 dollars whether it be
three years or five years from now we
need to get there I can't answer that
question we will we will provide an
update on our quarterly conference call
coming up in May but look we are focused
on making sure we lead our industry in
total shareholder return we will
continue to stay focused on that and
we'll continue to build the premier
growth pharmaceutical company in the
industry and they're gonna have an
exciting future and as your focus as you
focus within your own company
what kind of restructuring is still need
to take place well we had before Pfizer
came we had looked at restructuring our
company to better deal with the
divestiture of our generics business
atiba we have that plan it's been
sitting on the Shelf we're gonna pull it
off the shelf this week we're gonna make
sure it it's fresh and is the right
thing to do and then we'll get moving so
we're we were prepared for this we
didn't want it to happen but we were
prepared for it so we're ready to go and
we'll be in great shape no it's just
looking back at the last 24 to 48 hours
were you completely blindsided by this
and how come you didn't decide to fight
it you moved to to stop the merger quite
quickly what was the thinking there and
what was the analysis in terms of what
you could have potentially done to fight
back at the Treasury yeah of course we
were surprised by this this was an
extraordinary change of the rules after
the game had started to be played but we
were prepared for it so that was the
good news
I think fighting it is is not in our
shareholders best interest it's not in
our employees best interest it would
have been a long protracted expensive
fight perhaps we could have won but
that's not a fair position to put our
shareholders in particularly when our
standalone prospects are growth
prospects our pipeline is so strong well
given that the government really stepped
in and roadblocked you in a very big way
in terms of your acquisition in growth
targets how about pricing how concerned
are you as you look to the government as
you look to the upcoming election the
pressure on drug pricing okay we always
take the pressure and drug pricing
seriously we've always at allergen and
forests before it have believed we have
a social contract with patients and
physicians to price our medicines based
on value and price them in a responsible
way we will continue to do that but the
most important thing we can do is find
cures and treatments for unmet need and
as long as we do that I think the value
equation will remain intact and we will
continue to flourish but there's the
invert do the new inversion rules
concern you that the government is quite
focused on you for example could this
tax policy change change again if we
have a new administration could the new
administration be even tougher on you in
terms of tax policy and pricing no I
don't think that that's a reality I
think the administration to be fair was
focused on Pfizer not Allergan the rules
that they passed today certainly were to
stop the inversion but they have
virtually no material impact on
standalone allergen and our ability to
continue to execute our strategy on a
go-forward basis so we are in a strong
position I don't believe we'll be
targeted in fact I think we have a
competitive advantage in that these
rules built a wall around the u.s. to
lock US companies
to being less competitive ball boy we're
a double based company has the freedom
to operate in a more competitive way
your business is that because you aren't
doing some of the earnings stripping
that they laid out and are you concerned
that they might come out with more and
look at other ways that there could be
inversion tactics that are stripped away
from some of the tax benefits that you
enjoy yeah so the way they targeting
earnings stripping in these rules
doesn't impact our structure that's not
the way we we we are structured that
being said I think it was very difficult
for them to do that and they've
acknowledged that there will be some
unintended consequences of the rules
they they wrote but they will not impact
our you know room so my sense is they've
really worked hard at Treasury to write
these rules
my sense is secretary Lew has already
said now it's up to Congress President
Obama has now also said now Congress
needs to make their next move and so I
think the hope here is that Congress
will do something to make the American
tax system more competitive for global
companies to operate well whether you
were blindsided or not clearly this is a
big smack who do you want to give your
political dollars to after this you know
I'm not going to endorse a specific
candidate but I do want to make sure
that the conversation of the politicians
changes from punishing companies to
figuring out how we can make America
more competitive we have much more
constructive dialogue do you believe
what they did here was punishing you
well I think they were trying to punish
Pfizer clearly they they accomplished
what they set out to do which was to
break the deal and
both Pfizer and Allergan will be fine
both have strong independent plans and
strategies and both will move on and
focus on those so while they broke the
deal I don't think they succeeded in
punishing anybody